Okay, you guys know that I'm moving in with my boyfriend.
And I know it's really stupid to, like, get new shit when you're moving,
but I couldn't resist these cute guy comes in a pack of eight,
this cute pack of glasses.
Look,
it's the one that looks like a soda can. And it has,
like, silicone molded wood top with the hole for the straw.
It's a glass straw, and it's borosilic glass,
so it's really,
really temperature strong.
It's shatter resistant or whatever.
It comes with the eight straws, and it comes with the straw cleaner.
Look at how cute this little set is.
I'm not even gonna take it all the way out until I move.
So hopefully, like, when I move, we have like a little party.
Cause it's like my four kids,
me and him,
and then like, two other guests have these cute little glasses.
I just love them.
They're so cute.
They're linked right here in the TikTok shop.